[Musique]
je me présente robert la doline je
représente l'exploitation de mon père
qui est située sur les eaux du tampon au
petit embout aujourd'hui on fait de la
vache allaitante on a quarante et une
vache en production et quatre vingts
génisses en production
aujourd'hui on est satisfaits haute
valeur environnementale
c'est un plus pour notre exploitation
aujourd'hui on a refait 7 hectares 40 de
prairies pour améliorer la qualité et la
quantité des vues qu'on veut augmenter
le cheptel passé à 56 vaches allaitantes
ensuite on a fait le chemin en béton
pour permettre de désenclaver
l'exploitation est aussi d'améliorer
tout ce qu'il dit
accessibilité à l'exploitation et le
chemin nous permet aussi de faire la
création de les tables on a fait une
création des tables de 56 places pour
nos vaches allaitantes les tables nous
permet d'alimenter les animaux et nous
permet de les protéger lors des cyclones
lors des intempéries et c'est un plus
pour la modernité de notre exploitation
nous on a pour objectif de m'installer
moi ils m'ont conjoints pour reprendre
exploitation de mon père dans cinq dans
les cinq ans qui viennent donc nous
c'est important pour nous de
privilégier la famille pour
l'exploitation et sans le fil des heures
on n'aurait pas pu reprendre une
exploitation avec autant de modernité
dans cinq ans on espère on espère
arriver au 56 vaches allaitantes avec
mon conjoint on espère reprendre
l'exploitation de mon père est perpétuée
l'élevage traditionnel de la réunion et
les vaches des eaux